now I am become death
destroyer of worlds
the 2023 film Oppenheimer gave us one of
the most remarkable and memorable movies
of the entire year but because it's
based on historical events let's find
out just how accurate Christopher
Nolan's film really is
and the answer in short is that it's
very accurate Nolan really did his
homework when making this biopic about
the father of the atomic bomb before we
get to some of the mistakes made in the
film and differences between what
happened in real life versus the movie
here is your official spoiler warning if
you don't want the movie spoiled come
back after you've watched it preferably
in IMAX just trust me it's worth it now
while the film got almost every aspect
of J Robert oppenheimer's life and of
the Manhattan Project right there were a
few mistakes and changes made to better
suit the spectacle of the big screen
over the history books let's start with
the doctor's early life as he studied
under a tutor named Patrick blackett
Oppenheimer at the time was very unhappy
in his life he struggled with his lab
work regularly making mistakes and
grappling with depressive thoughts it
was in this state that after some sort
of argument with his mentor Oppenheimer
used a toxic chemical to poison an apple
on Blanket's desk the film showed us
that he did this because black it made
Oppenheimer late to a lecture by Niels
Bohr but the real reason and the real
type of poison he used is unknown to
this day but he really did try to poison
his teacher instead of hastily running
to stop Neil's board from accidentally
eating it the next day as shown in the
filmhouse however the university found
out about the attempted poisoning and
Oppenheimer was almost expelled since no
one ate the apple though and because
oppenheimer's parents were wealthy
benefactors of the school they were able
to convince the Headmaster to allow
Oppenheimer to stay later Oppenheimer
moved a study under Max Bourne where he
was able to thrive and publish many
papers expanding on the work of Dr
Werner Heisenberg Heisenberg and
Oppenheimer were friends as shown in the
film before eventually becoming rivals
in the creation of the atomic bomb with
Heisenberg working for Germany and
Oppenheimer working for the United
States in the film it's shown the
Oppenheimer learned Dutch in just six
weeks in order to give a lecture this
actually is true Oppenheimer was very
gifted in learning several languages and
he really did learn how to speak Dutch
to give a lecture saying I don't think
it was very good Dutch but it was
appreciated in the film Oppenheimer is
shown to me a married woman named Kitty
with whom he eventually married himself
this is also true as Kitty was married
before getting pregnant with Oppenheimer
and later divorced her husband so she
could marry the father of her child also
just as the film showed Oppenheimer and
kitty gave their son to a friend to be
raised for the summer as they went
through a difficult personal time
powerful moments like these are what
really drives the emotion throughout the
film even though they may not be
essential to telling the story of the
creation of the atomic bomb in the film
we see Luis Alvarez running from a
barber shop after reading about some
scientists who had successfully split an
atom of uranium by bombarding it with
neutrons he ran to find Oppenheimer who
would attempt to prove that this was
impossible by writing out the math on
his Blackboard this actually happened in
real life and Alvarez successfully
repeated the process the next day
proving that a nuclear bomb could be
possible and reaffirming as the movie
says multiple times that theory only
goes so far the film shows several
scenes of Oppenheimer and Einstein
together as friends which is also
accurate the two became friends after
they met at Caltech and remained in
touch throughout the creation of the
atomic bomb although Einstein was not
nearly as involved in the project as
Oppenheimer the film also accurately
portrayed the fact that Albert Einstein
wrote a letter to President Roosevelt
stating that a massive bomb could now be
made through nuclear fission and that
Germany would likely be able to build
one themselves Oppenheimer was bad at
math but good with people and one man
saw him as a true genius Lieutenant
Leslie Groves the man in charge of
putting together the team that would
build an atomic bomb for the United
States Groves chose Oppenheimer to head
the Manhattan Project's secret weapons
laboratory meaning he would be in charge
of building the first atomic bomb for
the United States of America even though
he had several links to the Communist
Party Groves chose Oppenheimer because
he believed that he was one of the
smartest men alive one thing the film
didn't really portray however is that
Oppenheimer had never held a position of
leadership before he also hadn't
received any Nobel prizes as some of his
colleagues had before so he really
wasn't the most qualified person for the
job a quote from both the film and from
his real life writings Oppenheimer once
said my two great loves are physics and
New Mexico it's a Pity that can't be
combined the physicists truly loved the
desert landscape of New Mexico as he
spent time there in his Youth and even
had a ranch there it also provided a
great location for secrecy and for
setting off a large nuclear blast the
best remote and flat location the
Manhattan Project team could find was in
Los Alamos New Mexico known to the
outside world only as P.O box 1663 while
some of the events in Los Alamos were
dramatized in the film Nolan once again
stayed very true to the real events that
inspired the film Christopher Nolan
wanted to make that Los Alamos site as
historically accurate as possible so he
used archival footage of the real sight
to rebuild it for the film that's right
he had the entire site rebuilt totaling
54 buildings including a sawmill Stables
schools Apartments Laboratories
hospitals garages special cottages for
the project leads and maybe most
importantly labor and delivery buildings
during the time of the Manhattan Project
over one-fifth of the married women at
the site got pregnant and over 300
babies were born with their birth
certificates listing their place of
birth as P.O box 1663 in Santa Fe New
Mexico Oppenheimer originally thought he
would need anywhere from 6 to 50
scientists and some additional support
staff to make the bomb however the
Manhattan Project ended up employing and
involving 764 scientists and over 600
000 additional civilians and military
personnel but before we we get to how
the bomb was made really quick this
video is brought to you by skillshare
have you ever wanted to know how huge
scale cinematic movies like Oppenheimer
get made well skillshare is the place
for you skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of online
classes and members focused on a learn
by doing approach to teaching which
works really well for me skillshare has
classes on animation marketing
productivity graphic design and even CGI
but I'm most excited about Zach
Mulligan's class on cinematography
Basics because as you probably know I
love movies and almost all of my
favorite movies have excellent
cinematography including several of
Christopher Nolan's films such as the
Dark Knight Inception Interstellar and
even Oppenheimer so if you start to
notice my videos getting a lot more
cinematic well it's because of
skillshare skillshare has a special
offer for all of you and the first 1000
people that join skillshare using my
link will get one month of skillshare
for free Okay so let's say you only do
skillshare for an hour a day that's over
30 hours of classes you'll be getting
for completely free and no there's not a
catch it's actually 100 free for the
first month so if any of this interests
you I highly recommend that you click my
link down below sign up to skillshare
and start learning something new okay
now back to the video Nolan's film did a
great job of portraying how the first
atomic bomb was built but didn't do the
best job of specifying how long it took
and how many people were involved in all
it took over two years to construct the
bomb and it was proven to be possible in
1942 with a successful construction of
the first nuclear reactor otherwise
known as pile one this reactor was built
by Enrico Fermi and just as the movie
showed it was housed underneath the
football field at the University of
Chicago this reactor's construction
proved that a self-sustaining nuclear
chain reaction was possible so a nuclear
bomb would also be possible the
Manhattan Project team eventually
settled on an implosion bomb design
which would involve surrounding a core
of plutonium with explosives that would
increase the density of atoms in the
plutonium creating a chain reaction
resulting in a nuclear blast equal to
thousands of tons of TNT as shown in the
film The Bomb needed to be tested before
the Potsdam Conference where the
post-world War II peace talks would take
place so two days before the conference
the test firing of the explosives for
the implosion device was a failure even
though this test failed they decided to
move forward with the atomic weapon test
now known as Trinity on the next morning
July 16 1945 although there's no account
of the conversation between Oppenheimer
and the bomb technician who bet his
month's salary that the final weapon
test would work the film also shows us
how at one point Edward Teller who went
on to invent the hydrogen bomb had
worries that the nuclear weapon may
start a great enough chain reaction that
it would heat up the hydrogen in the
atmosphere causing it to fuse together
and become a giant fusion bomb setting
the atmosphere on fire after some
initial calculations however almost
every scientist involved in the project
dismissed the concern realizing that the
chances of this happening was as the
film stated near zero but it wasn't
Albert Einstein who Oppenheimer visited
to confirm this Einstein wouldn't have
been any good for that anyway as he
specialized in other kinds of science
instead Oppenheimer consulted Arthur
Compton who confirmed there was a near
zero possibility of such a catastrophe
happening but Enrico Fermi really did
take bets on Taylor's Theory before the
Trinity test as shown in the film on the
morning of July 16 1945 5 the day before
the Potsdam Conference Los Alamos New
Mexico began to see rain clouds and
heavy winds this weather would push back
the time of the atomic weapons
detonation to 5 29 am which would
produce an explosion equal to 25 000
tons of TNT the Shockwave from the blast
would be felt from over 160 kilometers
away and it produced a mushroom cloud
that would reach 12 kilometers high the
film doesn't zoom out beyond the
scientists and Military members who
watched the Trinity test at various
distances but the brightness of the
flame the sound of the explosion and the
shaking caused by the blast wave didn't
go unnoticed the force blew out windows
in nearby cities including Amarillo
Texas over 280 miles away where
residents could see the flash from their
doorsteps because of this the government
planted a story that an ammunition
magazine had exploded but that no one
was hurt so as to maintain the Project's
secrecy one somewhat funny moment from
the test in the film included physicist
Richard Feynman getting into a truck to
watch the atomic bomb test from behind a
windshield because he said it would
protect him from the ultraviolet
radiation and this actually happened I'm
probably the only guy who saw it with a
human eye he said as everyone else
watched through dark glasses although
many people have joked online that
Christopher Nolan used a real nuclear
bomb for the detonation sequence he
actually used a mixture of practical
explosions chemical reactions and CGI to
generate the images we saw in the film
also the movie failed to show a rather
interesting result of the explosion
trinitate the explosion was so hot that
it turned the desert sand into a
glass-like material now known as
trinitite named after the bomb Test's
name Trinity selecting the targets for
the atomic bombs was a complicated
process that involved many people
including Oppenheimer and Secretary of
War Henry Stimson Stimson however gets
turned into a sort of caricature in the
movie stating that they wouldn't bomb
Kyoto because he and his wife
honeymooned there although he and his
wife did visit Kyoto in real life they
didn't take their honeymoon there and it
wasn't the reason why Kyoto wasn't
chosen the decision was more nuanced and
complicated and had far-reaching
consequences for the cities that were
bombed on August 6th and 9th 1945 the
United States detonated two atomic bombs
over the Japanese cities of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki respectively the aerial
bombings together killed between 129 000
and 226 thousand people most of whom
were civilians and remained the only use
of nuclear weapons in an armed conflict
the film depicts the use of these bombs
as absolutely necessary to ensure the
surrender of the Japanese people but
many historians argued this wasn't the
case and that Japan was likely to
surrender even without the use of
nuclear weapons after the detonation of
the two bombs over Japan Oppenheimer
became a national hero even appearing on
the cover of Time Magazine he was placed
on the general advisory committee for
nuclear weapons on which he vehemently
argued for arms control when he was
asked about when the arms control talk
should have begun with Russia
Oppenheimer said the day after the
Trinity test he had created a way for
Humanity to destroy itself and in a 1965
NBC News documentary Oppenheimer
recalled a quote from the Hindu text the
bhagavad-gita saying now I am become
death the destroyer of worlds he said
that the verse came into his mind as he
watched the test which had unfolded two
decades earlier and marked the first
detonation of a nuclear device the
biggest departure from reality in the
entire film stems from this important
quote instead of stating this quote in
an NBC documentary Oppenheimer says in
the film during an intimate scene with
Florence Pugh's character Gene tatlock
not only is this moment in the film
entirely fictional but it's drawn
condemnation from the Indian government
in a letter addressed to Christopher
Nolan on Twitter India's information
commissioner Uday maharkar called the
scene featuring The revered scriptures a
scathing attack on Hinduism and a direct
assault on the religious beliefs of a
billion tolerant Hindus he urged Nolan
to remove the scene from the film but it
remained in the film as he intended
later in his life Oppenheimer was
essentially put on trial for a security
clearance because he used his status to
push for arms control Louis Strauss
played by Robert Downey Jr who looks a
lot like Strauss in real life pushed for
the hearing on oppenheimer's security
clearance and interfered in the hearing
because Oppenheimer had humiliated
Strauss about Isotopes at an earlier
conference the hearings found several
reasons as to why oppenheimer's security
clearance would eventually be revoked
with the main one being his ties to the
Communist Party Oppenheimer had engaged
in an affair with Gene tatlock a
Communist Party member who later killed
herself and he even met with her at
least one time during the Manhattan
Project which raised many security
concerns his wife was also a former
Communist Party member so he was accused
of potential treason and Espionage it
was later confirmed that there were
actually Russian spies on the Manhattan
Project as seen in the film in 1953
Oppenheimer once again made the cover of
Time Magazine but this time in black and
white as his security clearance had been
revoked and His Image had been tarnished
during the construction of the bomb
Oppenheimer knew the weapon would likely
need to be used but he felt that
Hiroshima and Nagasaki weren't necessary
as shown in the film Oppenheimer met
with President Truman with whom he asked
to begin Arms Control talks and just as
in the film Oppenheimer said he felt he
had blood on his hands Truman however
countered saying that the blood was
actually on his hands even going so far
as to call Oppenheimer a crybaby
scientist and kicked him out of the Oval
Office the film failed the show however
that Truman would later honor
Oppenheimer with a presidential citation
and a medal for mayor in 1946. also as
one fun final detail the film got
correct one of the Senators who voted
against the confirmation of Strauss into
the president's cabinet was Senator John
F Kennedy future president of the United
States all in all Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer may be one of the most
historic accurate biopics to hit the big
screen in a long time and his attention
to detail will surely pay off subscribe
for more content about your favorite
movies and if you liked the video check
out the one on your screen too
[Music]